aktuell liegen fünf monate lockdown am
stück hinter uns und manche trifft es
härter als andere
die gastrobranche zb mit ihren 2,4
millionen beschäftigten jeder vierte
betrieb denkt inzwischen schon ans
aufgeben
es hat und die ganz große pleitewelle
ist ja eh nur aufgeschoben weil man
vorübergehend unser insolvenzrecht
ausgesetzt hat zuviel insolvenzen vor
der bundestagswahl die machen auch nur
unnötig schlechte laune
das war wohl der gedanke es wirklich
schlimm was da passiert mit dieser
branche und die folgenden bilder meine
damen und herren ich sag's als warnung
sind nichts für schwache nerven
für dieses fass bier kommt jede corona
lockerung zu spät
die privatbrauerei bischof in winnweiler
muss den inhalt von 2800 bierfässern
wegschütten das haltbarkeitsdatum des
biers läuft ab abgelaufen das bier oder
wie ich es nenne kölsch gewusst viele
gastronomen haben zum glück eine
betriebsschließung versicherung gezahlt
wenn der staat zum beispiel wegen einer
pandemie dem betrieb dicht macht also
theoretisch praktisch haben viele wirte
ihren laden zu aber den kaffee auf ich
habe schon wirklich das gefühl
das den versicherungen ihre
versicherungsnehmer und damit ihre
kunden wirklich scheißegal sind
ich habe gedacht ich kriege geld weil
ich eine versicherung habe und dann
könnte aus konnte
denkst du so arschkarte im grunde das
jahresmotto 2021 denkst du so arschkarte
da bleiben den betroffenen meist nur die
gerichte der klageweg gerade letzte
woche hat ein münchner gericht zugunsten
der versicherung entschieden leider
andere urteile gar nicht wenige geben
aber den gastronomen recht und die
pointe ist in vielen
versicherungsverträgen stehen sogar ganz
explizit sätze wie der versicherer
leistet entschädigung wenn die
zuständige behörde aufgrund des
infektionsschutzgesetzes den
versicherten betrieb schließt steht da
und dann gibt's trotzdem oft kein geld
weil und jetzt kommt mit 19 nicht
explizit im vertrag erwähnt wird
wie denn auch das virus gibt es ja erst
seit kurzem unter anderem der
branchenprimus allianz zahlt wohl sehr
ungern gegen korona sehr und versucht
jetzt wie viele andere versicherer auch
altverträge zu kündigen und die neun
decken dann eben keine pandemien ab
soviel zum thema allianz fürs leben er
wobei die allianz hat es wahrscheinlich
auch nicht so leicht in diesen zeiten
oder bei seinen aktionären dagegen zeigt
sich das unternehmen großzügig schüttete
im corona jahr 2020 eine dividende von
rund vier milliarden euro aus sie haben
richtig gehört nur vier milliarden
verdammtes corona hh kinder was war das
doch früher schön was waren das für
unschuldige zeiten als
versicherungsvertreter noch regelrechtes
darf waren
ich sag nur hallo herr kaiser und wann
der kaiser dieser versicherungsform
ziehen
er hat mit der oma bestimmt wieder einen
haufen kraft an
gut dann nehme ich also die paragliding
versicherung oder sie nehmen gleich zwei
das ist noch sicher war
doch die fresse ludwigsburg
was macht der kaiser eigentlich heute
verkauft wahrscheinlich
brandschutzversicherung in der hölle die
versicherungsbranche kriegt übrigens
regelmäßig schützenhilfe von der politik
in bayern zum beispiel hatte man die
geniale idee dass die den notleidenden
gastronomen statt 100 prozent der
versicherungssumme
doch einfach pauschal 15 prozent zahlen
ja ein absoluter scheiß deal
deshalb muss man den mit leckeren
metaphern irgendwie schmackhaft machen
die versicherungen sind auf die gastro
branche auf die gastronomische und
zugegangen sollen jetzt schon also die
haben jetzt schon das halbe hendl traut
fertig am tisch alternative wäre gewesen
wenn ich mich zurücklehnen darf sich
sagt er läuft ist händel irgendwo hinten
in geordneter umfang dieses ein dann
hast du ein ganzes händel geboxt aber
den rechtsanwalt dazu nicht garantiert
nicht dass du das ganze handel jeweils
zehn wirst ich garantiert das halbe
hendl braut fertig am tisch der hühner
ruby ruby ich will ja nicht
klugscheißern aber brat fertige händel
sind von natur aus rom
dann brauche ich schon wieder eine
salmonellen versicherung am ende wird
wohl erst der bundesgerichtshof klären
ob die gastronomie geld kriegen oder
nicht bis dahin kann es aber noch sehr
lange dauern und dann sind viele
betriebe leider pleite oder sie lassen
sich in ihrer not auf sittenwidrige
vergleich ein hat leider methode lisa
wenn versicherer was können dann
kundenvermögen hier eine ehemalige
mitarbeiterin verrät worauf es ankommt
man wurde ein bisschen wie ein hund
erzogen dass man das gelernt hat immer
abzulehnen und alles möglichst
loszuwerden das war nicht meine aufgabe
alles einfach schnell abzulehnen wie den
hund dressiert ja wer lehnt den antrag
ab
sie lehnt den antrag ab du wir deutschen
haben 440 millionen
versicherungsverträge im moment werden
so gar kein witz unfallversicherungen
gegen impfschäden verkauft ist
eigentlich von der krankenversicherung
abgedeckt aber warte mal da kommen wir
doch direkt die nächste geschäftsidee
liebe kunden was haben wir ihnen nicht
schon alles an die backe gelabert
handyversicherung
krankentagegeldversicherung für katzen
direktions ausfallversicherung aber
jetzt kommt was richtig geiles die
versicherungs versicherung für 129 euro
im monat versichern wir sie gegen das
risiko dass eine unserer versicherungen
im schadensfall nicht zahlt und da die
am ende höchstwahrscheinlich auch nicht
zahlt empfehlen wir die versicherungs
versicherungs versicherung sicher eine
gute idee um die branche muss man sich
wirklich keine sorgen machen
1500 euro gibt jeder deutsche haushalt
pro jahr im schnitt für versicherungen
aus 30 prozent mehr als noch vor zehn
jahren
ich begrüße valerie niehaus vom gdv dem
verband deutscher versicherer ergo keine
frau mehr aus warum sind wir deutschen
so besonders anfällig für versicherungen
die man gar nicht braucht ganz einfach
wir wollen maximale sicherheit ja es
heißt nicht umsonst der deutsche
schnallt sich auch in der waschanlage an
der trägt beim sex und fahrradhelm also
wirklich mein mann der trägt beim sex
egal
große versicherer erforschen tatsächlich
die ängste ihrer kunden also als
erfahrene verkäuferin guck ich sie an
und denke da ausfallversicherung ob das
gibt wenn sie wollen also man kann hier
wirklich alles verkaufen
es gibt kein witz hochzeit zurücktritt
versicherungen die zahlen aber nur wenn
die hochzeit wegen unfall oder
wohnungsbrand ausfällt aber eben nicht
beim naheliegenden grund dass die braut
kurz vorher merkt was er für ein
vollidiot ist oder sich am tag der
trauung eine neue brille gekauft hat ich
habe für diesen sommer tatsächlich eine
reisegepäckversicherung abgeschlossen
der clip wurde das flyer gleich doppelt
besteuert
erstens fährt niemand diesen sommer
irgendwohin und zweitens damit die
versicherung bei gepäckverlust zahlt
müssen sie den ganzen urlaub quasi auf
dem koffer sitzen ja sonst nennen wir
das grobe fahrlässigkeit also eigentlich
dürften sie hätte ihn nicht mehr
auspacken
es ist was zu leicht versicherungen zu
verticken ein vertreter verrät den
wichtigsten trick von allen
das sagt dickel klappern
es gibt einen moment wo gier oder angst
ein so große einflussnahme auf ihre
entscheidung haben dass eine rein
rationale steuerung nicht mehr möglich
ist und wenn sie genügend angst gemacht
haben sie genug mit dem sack der oder
klappert haben
dann steigt in einigen fällen die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass sich jemand so
etwas drängen lässt dass er eigentlich
nicht möchte angst essen hirn auf und
ich sage gott sei dank sind wir so ein
schiff erfolg angst es für meine branche
ein nie versiegender rohstoff so eine
krankenversicherung für haustiere zum
beispiel kann man gar nicht verkaufen
ohne gute fotos von überfahrenen bunten
brauche ich dann wirklich eine
versicherung gegen glasbruch weiß ich
nicht denn hier viel glas kaputten
dagegen also von hier aus mir gefällt
ihr bild vom kunden aber gar nicht als
wären wir alle nur manipulierbare
trottel oder was freuen sie sich doch
dass wir produkte anbieten die
individuell auf ihre bedürfnisse
zugeschnitten sind
haben sie herr welke zum beispiel mal
nachgedacht über unsere brandneue gag
absturz versicherung das eine tolle
sache
falls ihnen hier ein gag verreckt zahlen
wir ihnen den macher ausfall ich guck
ihre sendung regelmäßig das ist eine
versicherung die sie wirklich brauchen
ich weiß nicht jan böhmermann hat schon
unterschrieben hat immer hier steht ein
anspruch entsteht nur in tv studios mit
publikum
wir haben doch gar keine scheiße valerie
niehaus
hallo youtube unten könnt ihr den kanal
abonnieren er deutet nach unten in die
infobox
neben mir gibt es weitere interessante
videos verlinkungen komma vielen dank
[Musik]